The joe rogan experience.
Can I answer?
Can I give a shout out and
can I tell you one story?
Are you giving a shout out?
Are you a black guy or a white rapper?
And I give a shit is happening here
to give a shout out to one guy who I met,
he's a guy named Matt Ruskin,
right?
And he was in the marines in Iraq
and they had these five clubs in,
in Iraq.
And they would do the marine
for like forest week on these,
these were tough motherfuckers.
And he was doing this,
uh,
they'd had these bike clubs and they
would fight them the fuck out of each
other.
And he,
he's like 200 pounds.
And he would fight guys who were two 50.
He would fight guys or one 50.
He was fighting,
he would beat them all.
And he came back and he started doing MMA.
He started finding him and me
and he hooked up with this guy,
one of the Gracies and,
and you're taught him Brazilian Jujitsu,
of which he was I believe,
five time world champion.
Uh,
the Gracie,
which guy?
I'm forgetting his fucking name.
He's fucking amazing.
He is amazing.
Crazy.
Yeah.
He's a Gracie and I went
down to visit Roger Gracie.
See?
Well wait,
is he a compete at
heavyweight heavyweight?
He was heavy.
We was five time World Brazilian
Jujitsu champion and uh,
see I'm going to get no hoe.
Hollis Gracie's very
famous but well Hollis,
the son of holes,
right?
It's great.
I'm going to get in shit
for forgetting his name.
That's okay.
Thinking about it first.
He's a real good looking guy.
He was a model.
Real good looking guy.
Hickson Hickson is the most handsome
of all time and the greatest of all.
This guy was actually a model in Brazil.
I'm not gay.
And Matt Ruskin,
if you can,
if you can tweet me.
He was a model.
Yeah.
Model and a great fight.
Somebody lied to you and guide and
structure at Sears and five time global to
champion.
We are now in a swamp of disinformation.
No,
it's true.
No wick PDA.
And if someone can tweet us right now,
problem,
we don't have a great Matt,
how are you?
Okay.
I'm here with Joe Rogan.
We're talking about the Gracies.
Let me talk to this and I'm saying,
who's the Gracie?
Daniel.
Gracie.
Well,
Daniel Daniel Gracie world.
Uget you champion how many times?
Three times.
Okay.
Yeah,
so he's,
he's a global.
Uh,
did you,
did you champion a Daniel Gracie?
I want,
I'm going to put you on a Rogan.
Hold on a second.
Talking to him,
by the way,
Matt Ruskin is a fucking awesome dude.
And Matt.
Yeah.
What's going on in,
how's everything?
Can you hear it?
Yeah.
Uh,
what's up Matt w.
W.
W how do you know powerful?
Shane Smith from vice.com
shaved Smith walked
into a fucking work and
they told him he needed to lose
weight if you were going to die.
How rude.
Because first of how rude,
how bout how bout,
hey,
settle down.
First of all,
how about you tell him first
and foremost that you love them.
You don't have to go right into the meat.
You're,
you're a fat fuck and you're going to die.
He knows how much you love him.
You say that,
but is that touch alleviate the
pressure of your own personal oh,
no.
Gay stuff.
This is a late night podcasts.
Misses a lot of dudes and
elicited this in the shower.
I'm sorry.
Keep going
Matt.
No gay stuff,
Bro.
This is late night.
I did some work with midwives before,
before five land.
They did this whole thing of me when
I was training for one of my fights.
Uh,
they said their friend Thomas
around with me for a while.
Um,
tell him about when we went
down with Daniel Gracie.
Yeah.
Uh,
Jordan to a weapons bizarre with them.
Daniel Gracie.
Yeah.
With Daniel.
Here's the thing about Daniel Gracie.
Daniel Gracie is a very,
very,
very talented Brazilian Jujitsu fighter.
But his real last name I don't
believe was initially Gracie.
I think he sort of,
and those cousins,
his hands,
his cousin.
Yeah.
And I think his,
his,
his mom's name is Gracie,
but his dad's name and his
birth name was not Gracie.
Right?
Yeah.
I believe this is what I believe.
I believe he's a very talented fighter,
but I believe this whole
idea of connecting yourself
to the word Gracie is it is
ultimately very self defeating
and when a guy does that,
I almost want to pull them aside.
If the look Daniel,
you're a bad motherfucker or
whatever the fuck your last name is,
it doesn't matter.
You know you need to get your head
wrapped around the fact that that's all
bullshit.
Gracie is a great name but it's 2013
and when he was competing eight,
nine,
10 whatever the fuck it was,
2000 it doesn't matter what matters is
how good you are and adopting the name.
Gracie almost makes people think like,
oh well this guy is trying to get a
little extra attention for for no reason.
The the,
the,
the world championships or the world
championships and you either mounted guy
who take us back,
you tap him,
whatever you do,
you either do or you don't do and it
doesn't matter if your name is Marcello
Garcia who's unbelievably respected.
I mean Marcel Garcia is the top of
the pyramid when it comes to Brazilian
Jujitsu.
In the world today in 2013 or Gracie,
it doesn't matter.
So whatever his name was,
what was his real name?
Matt.
How many times you've
been hiding in your life?
Don't lie to me many times.
What have you been hiding your life?
Yeah,
more than 10 is it more than 10
okay.
Yes.
Okay,
so we could probably go camping together.
How many times do you eat and pot brownies
and thought about chicks you fingered
when you were 14?
You were really upset like Kyra.
Gracie more than 10.
That's why I love talking to you,
Matt.
Let's keep it together,
But there was a few guys that did that.
Uh,
the Gracie thing where they use,
what I'm going to say is Daniel Gracie's,
whatever you want to go,
what am I going to say?
He's a bad motherfucker,
but oh,
by the way,
he took us around Brazil.
He took us to the valley.
Tudo Jim's.
He took us to the gyms.
He took us with Matt and I
got to say it was fucking,
I got to say,
you see a different
level of shit down there.
Then you'll see anywhere else they did.
These guys trained like motherfuckers
to hear this mat and
do you agree with this?
At the time was like the worst of the
worst and we had to go ask the boss if we
could come in here and
tell the boss you're here,
no problem.
Just don't film the kids with the guns.
And we're looking around,
we're like what kids,
what guns?
We take a call like a
left turn down the street
and
I mean it was just wall to wall.
14 year olds,
15 year olds with like
military grade weapons.
I mean you got to picture the,
it was like one word,
shorts,
flip flops,
you know like a 1989 Luther Campbell
like gold road chamber to medallion,
you know,
mouth them,
mouth of the side to
side mount gold teeth,
fucking you know,
collapsible stock and forwarded a
cod grenade launcher the whole nine.
I mean these kids were
armed to the fucking teeth
and
every one that we went down there with
was just looking around like holy shit.
You can never end a story by saying like,
Holy Shit,
I am a very good story.
I was with Matt.
However you leave us can say this.
I was,
I was with Matt was there
was 14 year old kids.
Like I said,
like,
you know,
one of the 11 times,
don't lie to me,
Matt say yes,
yes.
Okay,
listen Bro,
I feel what you're saying.
And I was only fucking around.
I was filling some dead space where
we're trying to recalibrate our reality
duty,
your circumstances and your
story being paradigm shifting.
I'm not that fucked up.
Listen,
I want to tell you Matt,
man,
I'm giving you a shout out.
I love you.
This guy fucking is an awesome guy.
Ex Marine and a fighter.
I love you Matt.
Matt,
I'm very sorry.
They got dragged into a podcast.
It was just a phone call for you and
all the sudden Shane Swiss talking about
some crazy shit and you're like,
God dammit.
I got to tell the truth cause I'm Matt.
But,
but,
but then you had Ruskin
and I don't give a fuck.
But Daniel Gracie is a
bad ass mother fucker.
Yes,
unquestionably,
but was his real name Matt
would that
Daniel Gracie,
what is his real name?
Yeah.
Hi.
The last name,
the family name is Ozzy era.
There were similar as one of the two.
I know.
And I completely,
by the way,
I want to let everybody know is no
judgment involved in that whatsoever.
I completely understand why someone
who especially was in a situation where
there were a very talented guy and
they were trying to maximize the,
the sort of the,
this red of their name as far as possible
and the word Gracie because of hoists
and because of Horian and what they
would they accomplished in UFC one.
It was one of the most important
moments in the history of martial arts.
Would you agree,
Matt?
I agree
it's,
it's for people who don't know the
history of it or weren't there when it's
happening as martial artists,
it was one of the most
important moments ever.
It's like all of a sudden we
found out what really works.
Right,
right.
And those guys,
that name,
that Gracie name,
that shit's like cue tips or Kleenex,
you know,
it's anonymous.
I don't give a fuck about your tissues.
If you have tissues made by
Kraft macaroni and cheese,
if they're right next to clean x,
I'm taking the Kleenex.
Okay.
Cause they dominate as does the NFL.
They dominate as well.
You know what I'm saying?
Matt?
Jesus Christ back me up.
I got to tell you.
I think the name Angela,
100% thank you Matt.
Thank you.
In what way?
Like Daniel,
Daniel was a
all was fighting a bride.
They told them to take,
take the family name.
You know why do you know why
they were all fighting it?
Do you know why?
Yeah,
cause they're smart mother fuckers because
they're smart motherfuckers and they
know how to make that paper son.
Hmm.
Okay.
Hi Matt.
Don't don't freeze up on me.
Now we're in the deep end of the pool.
Matt,
we're not close to the lip hanging there.
Did you see the right math teacher?
Heather,
are you with me buddy?
I'm sorry.
Listen,
Matt,
I need to apologize to you as a human.
You didn't know what the
fuck was going on here.
You get dragged into this conversation.
Shane Smith calls you.
It's a where do you live,
sir?
No,
don't tell me.
East Coast,
west coast or mountain time.
He's coast.
Oh,
too late as fuck.
What I'm trying to say is
Matt is an awesome dude.
Do you hear this mat?
He say he said Matt isn't Shane Smith
Just said Matt is an awesome dude and then
your grace.
He's an awesome guy and Daniel
grace is an awesome dude.
And what and what you showed me
credit.
Any of that.
We're not trying to discredit any of that.
Matt,
you understand this,
correct?
No,
not yet.
In three minutes.
Listen,
what's important,
Matt,
is you understand that I respect and
adore Daniel Gracie and anybody gets in
there.
I just think she had a,
I could be have been there when Hendo
and all those other guys are trying to
talk Daniel into using the last name.
Gracie.
Oh,
so let's think this shit
through side federally.
Silva did pretty good.
What's the name?
Silva.
Okay.
We're going to be fine.
We don't need,
Gracie was okay.
Are you crazy?
That's your name.
Hanzo.
Hey,
Dez hens,
or do you support this?
Daniel character.
Yeah.
What did the fuck difference does it make?
What noise you make with your mouth
that represents his last name?
Are we cool?
Jesus Christ for the
greater good of humanity,
the world.
How about we forget about
imperial dictatorships and names
that dominate sports history.
If you feel me,
Matt,
did you know eating marijuana
is different if you,
hey,
Matt.
Matt,
I'm sorry.
Dude.
This is so rude.
You love him.
I love you,
Matt.
I'm so sad that I dragged you into this
and even though I did it with no malice,
say Matt,
Matt,
Ruskin,
Bat Ruskin,
do this to be mean.
I just did this because that's my nature.
I am the Scorpion.
You are the frog.
This is how shit goes down.
I didn't mean to do this.
Matt Ruskin is a Beautiful Matt Ruskin.
Well,
you do.
We do my podcast.
Yeah,
I would be happy to hear your thoughts,
sir.
I'd be honored if you would
do my podcast when we do.
Will you do with Shane?
I would definitely do it with Shane.
Of course
that happens have just opened up in
a hot tub in San Diego with the dog.
Stop it.
No dolphins and no Sharman I think would
be does ever experiment with a dolphin,
Matt?
Yeah.
Just tell him you love him.
Matt.
Have you ever watched a Rodeo
and felt sorry for the bowls
that
nothing.
Listen,
man,
I love the fuck out of,
even though we've never
met.
He's a good man.
If Shane Smith says you're good,
man,
you're a good man.
Do you feel me?
All right,
let's move.
Okay.
Jihad.
Oh,
cooking.
That was one of the most,
the least entertaining
did that broke my face.
That's,
that's got with one of the funniest
shit things I've ever seen in my life.
My face hurts.
[inaudible]
hello?
Hello?